en annonçant le 15 mars 81 son attention
de réunifier le système éducatif
le candidat à l'elysée françois
mitterrand se doutait-il qu'il ouvrait
le dossier le plus difficile du secteur
depuis trois ans ce débat n'a cessé
d'être l'objet de vives controverses
janvier 82 alain savary ouvre les
premières négociations avril première
réponse au ministre plus de cent mille
personnes réclament à la porte de pantin
le maintien de l'enseignement privé de
l'éducation de notre jeunesse
tout au plus vif la nation le 9 mai au
bourget fête du centenaire de l'école
laïque devant 400 mille personnes le
premier ministre rappelle l'objectif du
gouvernement le 20 décembre le ministre
présente ses propositions
proposition rejetée dès le lendemain par
l'enseignement catholique
après sept mois d'accalmie les
négociations reprennent dans un climat
plutôt favorable l'objectif de cette
entreprise n'est pas de contraindre il
est de procéder par étapes à une
rénovation d'ensemble du système
national d'enseignement optimisme de
courte durée les négociations traînent
le projet achoppe fin février 84 sur
quelques points et notamment la
titularisation des maîtres et on ne peut
pas céder sur les conséquences
c'est-à-dire finalement le projet d'un
établissement qui chez nous est de
nature confessionnelle les conséquences
le 4 mars 84 manifestation imposante de
l'enseignement privé soutenue par
l'opposition à versailles le 25 avril
réplique des partisans de la laïcité et
des partis de gauche
place de la bastille à paris à
l'assemblée le climat se durcit
le poème ministre hausse le ton rpr et
udf trouve dans ce débat un terrain
favorable avec pour slogan les libertés
sont menacées
la manifestation monstre du 24 juin à
paris pour la défense de l'école privée
devient avec le soutien de l'opposition
un rassemblement pour la défense des
libertés
c'est ce climat de plus en plus malsain
qui a sans doute conduit le président de
la république a retiré le projet de loi
d'alain savary
reste maintenant le plus difficile
présenter un nouveau texte qui calmerait
les passions c'est à dire qui
garantirait la paix scolaire
cela ne sera pas simple